[Music]
hey everyone I'm Alicia Malone welcome
to Fandango indie movie guided this is
the little show where I let you know
about these smaller films that are
coming out in theaters that are well
worth your money let's start with the
glass castle now this is directed by
Destin Daniel Cresson and it retains him
with Shari Larsen the last time these
two were together was with the brilliant
indie short term 12 all these walls are
gone in place for 3-inch glass glass
glass glass this can stay does it not
look lovely
yellow stands for happiness and
creativity this place doesn't have any
running water or electricity ignore her
she was more without vision the Glass
Castle is based on a memoir by Jeannette
Wells who had a very unconventional
upbringing and it flashes back and forth
between the present day where the
central character Jeanette's character
is played by brie Larson and the early
years which is played by child actresses
you've got the wonderful Woody Harrelson
and Naomi Watts who are playing her boho
parents throughout all the different
time frames and really this film is an
excellent showcase for actors you should
be a change of us just because we choose
a different lifestyle on you being
homeless in New York City does not count
as a lifestyle choice well if we heard
for me more you'd know that we found a
lovely place on the Lower East Side
Laurie said you're squatting in an
abandoned building it doesn't get
sentimental but it is very very moving
and I think everyone can relate to
different family dynamics
Jeanette's childhood was unusual and
there were huge drawbacks to the way she
lives but there were also a lot of
advantages and maybe she wouldn't have
wanted it any other way
like the people in Firebird deadly you
were born to change the world not just
add to the noise why do you think all of
us ran away from you we were drowning
this is a great little drama which shows
once again that brie Larson is a woman
well worth watching check out the glass
castle
it's available in semi limited theaters
it's going into a less than 2,000
theaters but hopefully you'll be able to
catch this one
[Music]
the next movie is a brilliant satire all
about social media it's called Ingrid
goes with a couple that yogas together
things together hashtag perfect true
romance I'm hashtag congratulations
this does Audrey Plaza who plays Ingrid
who's obsessed with Instagram she just
rolls through it all throughout the day
and she comes across this Instagram
influencer who's played by elizabeth
Olsen
they become friends but soon enough it
all unravels worse by far as a course
interesting person I've ever met
I love you so much you're amazing this
is a great mixture of humor and drama I
also want to give a shout out to O'Shea
Jackson jr. once again here he shows how
fresh vibrant and funny hands I need you
to tell everyone you're my boyfriend
why are you acting ugly very good like
these people don't if you're like me and
sometimes you get a bit disillusioned
with the idea of social media which
likes to promote these both life that
people project the very curated moments
of everyone's life
if you got lower I would be better in
the first yeah oh thanks to the back
then you should definitely check out
Ingrid goes where
a movie which got huge buzz coming out
of the Cannes Film Festival is also out
this weekend it's called good time and
it stars Robert Pattinson I got to come
clean with you about what I told you
about my brother here I told you about
the program he's forced to attend a now
you shouldn't be there don't count your
chickens before they do you understand
that well this is directed by the sassy
brothers Benny and Joshua known for
their guerilla style filmmaking they
really go for the gritty handheld look
and Robert Pattinson plays a bank robber
in this film who is trying to get his
brother out of jail and even though he
is a pretty sketchy character who's
still intensely likeable and I think
that's the charm of Robert Pattinson I
am so impressed by his career Robert
Pattinson chooses to work with such
interesting directors and that is
definitely the case here with Benny and
Josh safty we're good
we've got another 10 grand to bold it up
where are you how much money can you get
right now roll oh my gosh you think I'm
doing this work I want to be mop like
the sassy brothers are also really
impressive with the way that they
elevate the art form I mean they are
really trying to make this indie film
something unique and it is a film that
is not going to be easily forgotten so
if a good time is playing near you even
though you might not have a good time
watching it you will have a very
valuable time so check it out this place
where we are now
can be a lot of fun if you ever you're
going to have a good time
and my last pick to watch this weekend
is the trip to Spain starring Steve
Coogan and Rob Brydon and here once
again they're playing versions of
themselves they're playing heightened
versions of themselves going on this
trip around Spain where they eat
delicious food and see all the wonderful
sights just go back from filming in New
York they want me to do publicity verses
and restaurant reviews this time a trip
to Spain I will plan it has all the
ingredients of the first two films in
fact it pretty much follows the exact
same recipe you've got the
impersonations
you've got the cameos from the
characters who we've met in the last
couple of films and you've got the kind
of swapping of roles between Rob Brydon
and si Coogan about who has the more
famous the more successful who has the
better life single versus married and
they do explore some really deeper
issues amongst all the love just got
those kids in squeeze them in quickly
yeah yeah I'm not win the full Mick
Jagger and having him at he's having
another one at seven talk to our staff
now I met him I have I was at a party I
was leaving yeah and I heard from the
balcony group
Rob Rob Rob Rob hey Rob Rob I thought he
didn't read into the pole but now and
the delicious food I think if this movie
is playing at one of those dynein
theaters and it should be then
definitely go and watch it there because
it'll make your mouth water it may be
more of the same but if you are a huge
huge fan of the series like I am then
you will gobble it up check out the trip
to Spain it is out in limited theaters
this weekend come come Mr Bond you enjoy
the scallop just as much as I do
bottoms up goodbye mr. part should pay
more attention to your chef is working
for a Majesty government you to make me
a lot how do you have a sieve he'll be
somewhere talking to a nun then asking
them she's heard of Judi Dench to recap
my recommendations look out for these
four films the glass castle starring
brie Larson Ingrid goes west with Aubrey
Plaza and Elizabeth Olsen
good time with Robert Pattinson and the
trip to Spain with Z purgin and Rob
Brydon she was only 16 years old I am
terrible at impersonation but good with
recommendations you can tweet me an
Alicia Malone or if you're watching on
YouTube
and make sure you comment below because
I always read your replies and I try to
comment back whenever I can I'll see you
next week
[Music]